denise richards reveals her youngest
daughter has special needs
so how's baby Eloise she's good she is
so good she's amazing she's just so
delightful
the 47 year old adopted Eloise now seven
years old in 2011 but is just now
opening up about her developmental
challenges to People magazine's the star
tells the publication Eloise has a
chromosomal disorder that has caused a
lot of developmental delays for her
Denise said she recognized
Eloise needed special attention from an
early age she didn't reach typical
milestones for babies quote she wasn't
able to sit up on her own for a very
long time and she didn't start walking
until she was 2 and that was with
physical therapy today Denise says
Eloise can only say a handful of words
quote there are times when she feels
like her age and understanding and then
other times when it feels like she's
emotionally 3 years old I don't know if
Eloise is ever going to talk like a
typical child but as a parent you want
what's best for your children and you
just do it the best gift we can give our
kids it's time so I always try to
obviously they're my first priority
Denise of course has two other daughters
14 year old Sam and 13 year old Lola
whom she shares with her ex Charlie
Sheen and fans will get to know her
whole family a little bit better on her
first season of The Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills
so do your girls get what you do now
they in the last couple years really get
it I think for a long time they thought
I just worked in a trailer have they
gotten any of the showbiz bug would they
want to be and go into acting
I think Lola could with she's kind of
mentioned things a little bit you know
she's asked me a little bit if she when
she's older if she can be an actress and
I feel really older you can be anything
you want so you would be okay with it
yeah I mean I can't you know I've been
so blessed and
I have a wonderful life I'm lucky I get
to do what I love so if that's their
passion I would never want to stop that
I wouldn't want my parents trying to
stop me when I was you know acting so
whatever they want to do I just want
them happy and follow their passion in
their heart
[Music]